welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for the batman which robert
pattinson's batman speaks well mostly
with his fists which is how we like it
now solving the riddler zodiac style
ciphers in the first trailer awoke
inside me an investigative obsession
that i will now focus with a frame by
frame breakdown of this trailer all the
clues you missed for this film's deeper
mystery let's get started
[Music]
we open on this rain-soaked corner in
diner where enjoying a late-night latte
is paul dano as edward nashton this
movie's riddler a serial killer inspired
by the zodiac killer both the real-life
figure who may or may not have been
recently identified as well as the
zodiac's depiction in david fincher's
2007 film now notice how the rain is
almost constant in this film whenever
characters are on the lower levels which
i think is another element from director
matt reeves paying homage to david
fincher but instead of the director's
detective noir seven every exterior shot
in the city is covered with a heavy rain
downpour which fincher did to underline
the brutality of urban life now notice
how you can see a sign for the anchorage
stop lower gotham on the elevated train
platform which gives gotham a sense of
layers a division between the elite and
the underworld now actually batman's
batcave is beneath all of this in the
wayne terminus subway line which was
part of his family's original
infrastructure for gotham that we saw in
the batman earth 1 comics and apparently
the subway line has all been abandoned
it could be that the sins of his father
was really to sandwich all of the
destitute of gotham city into this
surface level stuck out in the rain with
the platforms weirdly left uncovered to
expose the poor working class to the
elements because they're on a train
platform why are they being covered in
rain there's really no overhang there
now framed here in the diner window
edward evokes another famous edward
edward hopper his famous nighthawks
painting creatures of the night but even
with obvious police lights flickering on
the window nashton doesn't run for it
and when gcpd swarms in he calmly raises
his hands to surrender it's as if he
anticipated being caught like this the
way john doe surrendering n7 or the
joker's surrender in the dark knight
were actually part of their master plans
also worth noting how odd it is for
gotham police to catch the big bad
criminal in a batman movie with batman
not even part of this raid meaning that
either gordon and his team were acting
on information that they did not share
with batman or batman didn't want to
move on nashton yet or couldn't nashton
was drinking out of and of course green
rimmed cup green bean the riddler's
favorite color and he traced in the foam
a perfect question mark it's almost out
of place how clean and crafted this is
in a movie that's otherwise total gritty
and sloppy making this a kind of calling
card from someone who wanted this to go
down this way and likely we'll have
several more of riddles marked exactly
this way that reveal themselves while he
is in police custody moving on
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
so the titles slam in synced with the
sounds of heavy circuit breakers
flipping the third of which ignites the
bat signal with the rain hitting those
hot shutters causing steam to form like
the rain trying to cool off the
hot-headed batman but failing miserably
and i love how this is not the sharply
welded stencil that we've seen in past
batman films but rather the shutters are
smashed in with a jagged piece of scrap
metal jammed in there and the effect is
a sloppier bat signal in the sky like a
chunk has been bitten out of the left
wing kinda like all the bruising this
batman endures as a younger brash or
vigilante who refuses to pull any
punches and rather than perched on the
roof of police headquarters as the bat
signal usually always is this signal is
tucked in a lower level of the building
still under construction and like
everything here exposed to the rainfall
reeves called this a year 2 batman and
neither he nor jim gordon have really
risen up to their unimpeachable statuses
in gotham's justice system moving on
it's not just a call
it's a warning
so we see the white face paint kids on
the train and then the shots of that
train platform from the previous trailer
meaning batman must have first spotted
these guys while they were on the train
and you can see it from the falling rain
on this side of the window and his and
reflection the glass batman was totally
watching them from outside the car and
then stalked them to the platform yeah
this is all super voyeuristic the kids
weren't doing anything wrong on that
train car they weren't harassing that
woman on her phone and yet batman doles
out total overkill that freaks them the
[ __ ] out now notice on the wall behind
these guys is a sign with the word
halloween now in addition to earth 1 and
ego jeff loeb's batman the long
halloween seems to be a major influence
on this film story as one of the great
batman detective stories but this could
also just be telling us what time of
year this is these kids might just be a
base paint not because they're part of a
gang because it's freaking halloween
yeah i know they shot him i just think
it could have been self-defense for this
creeper following them around now batman
does take a shot to the chest at point
blank range impressively deflecting off
his emblem which do look like detachable
weapons that could pop out of his chest
usable as knives or batarangs and as the
shot ricochet the guy behind him ducks
and does a quick double take reacting to
the bullet whizzing past him and then he
freaking electrocutes the shooter in the
neck to the point where a sizzle of
smoke wafts up from his neck apparently
a new terrifying function of batman's
gloves finger tasers moving on
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
before the gun
this is about a king
and river's the match
so here batman meets with edward nashton
while he is in lock-up and he wears a
straight jumpsuit labeled arkham state
hospital that was actually the name of
the hospital in joker where arthur fleck
obtained his mother's medical records
but the fact that this isn't arkham
asylum or like blackgate prison or even
the county jail suggests that nashden
might have been able to use an insanity
plea now notice that we never see paul
dano's face as edward nashton in this
trailer but we do get close with his
spectacled reflection in the window but
he does not flinch as batman pounds the
glass he just taunts i've been trying to
reach you maybe his communication has
been in the forms of these additional
crimes and riddles addressed to the
batman that reveal themselves while
nashton has been locked up he
pre-constructed all of this you could
actually see national paralleling
hannibal lecter in which these guys
imprisonment seems to have no effect on
their influence and in silence the
lamb's hand elector also left these
creepy little goodies ready to be found
by authorities that he just tucked away
years in advance on the outside this
riddler may also be inspired by the
riddler and batman's hush storyline in
which the riddler impressively
masterminded the whole conspiracy
against batman despite appearing to be
an already dealt with non-threat in the
plot now there's an overhead shot that
shows an explosion tear through the city
alley there's actually quite a few
overhead shots in this trailer the
cinematography is also reminiscent of
zodiac one of my favorite shots in that
movie where fincher followed the taxi in
which zodiac murdered taxi driver paul
stein bruce wayne shows up at the
funeral of gotham mayor don mitchell jr
that was the murder victim from the
crime scene in the first trailer selena
kyle also arrives wearing her tall lacy
boots set photos actually showed her on
the arm of john turturro as carmine
falcone now remember the first clue left
behind by the riddler asked what does a
liar do when he's dead and i was able to
decipher that code using the same double
letter substitution method mentioned by
robert greysmith in the zodiac film to
translate the creepy dad joke answer of
he lies still and i think once batman
decoded that he interpreted it as the
riddler's next target mitchell's funeral
a place where this liar politician
literally lies still like
and in nashton's eyes would continue to
lie as he is eulogized as a good man and
by the way the presence of a
owl on that card combined with the
riddler's later clue of if your justice
please do not lie what is the price for
your blind eye alluding to lady justice
the symbol of the court of law could
point to the court of owls possibly
being behind all of this but more on
that theory in a bit let's move on i can
take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
yeah we see some of the romantic
chemistry between selena kyle and batman
this is actually in the same spot that
gordon beams the bat signal you can see
it over there on the right and we see
the many forms of selena throughout this
trailer her shorter hair the wigs she
wears in disguise we also see colin
farrell as oswald cobblepot not yet the
penguin and the scarring on the right
side of his face is even more severe as
if whatever slashed him across the cheek
caused the muscles beneath to detach and
droop there's also some more recent
abrasions on his head and then in the
shot of andy circus is alfred this guy
also has a nasty looking scar across his
eyebrow is everyone in this movie
getting in bar fights thanks to display
for sponsoring this video display makes
high-quality art prints on metal they
have over a million great artist designs
including many from the worlds of gaming
anime and comics they have cool designs
from everything from alien to the
witcher in a really impressive marvel
collection check out some of my favorite
displays these in the link in the
description you will also get a sweet
discount they mount to your wall with a
magnet no tools needed no holes in the
wall with display you can build
collections of the things you're
passionate about right on your wall with
every disc plate that you buy you plant
one tree through displaced partnership
with the non-profit trees for the future
click the link in the description to see
some of our favorite displays and get
our special discounts 26 off one or two
displays and 36 off three or more
displays automatically applied to your
cart it's an amazing deal and only
available for a limited time and you'll
be supporting our channel and making
some major upgrades to your walls so
click the link and get your own display
meanwhile bruce wayne reads a newspaper
the masthead reads the gotham times with
the name mitchell across the banner
probably a headline reporting mayor
mitchell's murder and then bruce lays
out all of his regular evidence across
the floor i love these kind of shots now
i would say this is just like a
brainstorming room but there is police
tape across the bottom left so this
might have been a crime scene that the
cops already found but now it looks like
bruce has taken over the space carrying
spray paint so he was going to draw all
of this out i guess desperately trying
to get inside nashton's mind and it's
interesting how he is at the center
right at the question mark showing that
bruce wayne is really at the heart of
this mystery and he's surrounded by the
hatch marks that the riddler i guess
uses in his iconography as we see in
matt reeves release character posters
now in the bottom left is written
mitchell for mayor don mitchell and
photos i assume from his crime scene now
remember on his walls were newspaper
clippings of his recent mayoral
re-election over opponent bella rayal
and frame newspaper front page is
celebrating his bust of the maroney
crime family who are rivals to the
falcones make me think that carmine
falcone might have helped mitchell get
re-elected it is interesting how he
shows up to pay his respects at his
funeral coulson of course refers to
district attorney gil coulson peter
sarsgaard who was that guy who was
forced into plowing that suv through
mitchell's funeral and he was strapped
with an explosive collar an iphone on
his hand set to speaker mode and no more
lies taped over his mouth and then
another riddle for batman on his chest
now that suv was marked with the letters
d-o-a which could be a bit of wordplay
suggesting that the d.a the district
attorney was doa dead on arrival in the
first trailer we heard nashton's voice
saying if you
are justice please do not lie what is
the price for your blind
eye
and that audio sounded echoey as if it
was playing from golson's speakerphone
echoing in that church and i think those
are the words of the second riddle that
is taped to his chest the answer
referring to lady justice who is often
depicted blind and carries the scales
and the executioner's sword to behead
the guilty so the answer going by the
setup and punchline structure of the
first riddle is probably you get a head
a head and now we see savage written on
the floor referring to police
commissioner peter savage played by alex
ferns who i think will be the next
victim found beheaded actually the photo
to the left of the g in savage looks
like it could be a severed head now the
big clue here is outlined in a square
the sins of my father which bruce wrote
here so he's referring to his father
thomas wayne and i think it could be
connected to what nashton told bruce in
the first trailer you're part of
so what were thomas wayne's sins well in
the bottom right there's the phrase
renewal is a lie matt reeves has cited
the movie chinatown as an influence in
chinatown's a great movie it's the story
of how corrupt la leaders used water
infrastructure to control the city in
the 1930s and now there's a ton of
corruption and murder centered all
around that and notice how here nashton
has been targeting specifically city
leaders the mayor the d.a the police
commissioner and among those newspaper
clippings that nashton labeled lies in
the first trailer there was a
sub-headline that read seawall
construction stall so i think that
gotham leaders were trying to push
through a city renewal program that
involved redoing the infrastructure of
the city but corruptly doing it in a way
that would actually liquidate poor
communities and cruelly target innocent
people as criminals so they could lock
them up and steal their homes that's why
i think the wayne terminal that batman's
been using as a batcave is abandoned
because his ancestors the wayne family
originally had an underground subway
infrastructure that could have helped
the city but they shuddered it in order
to redline people into these ghettos and
now city leaders have been leaning on
their cozy relationship with an off the
books enforcer to clear out these
undesirables an enforcer called the
batman now i mentioned court of owls i
think there is a chance this movie could
connect with the court of owls an
amazing comic story line in which bruce
wayne learns that his wayne family was
actually connected to a cult called the
court of owls who has been secretly
running gotham city from the shadows for
centuries using an executioner named
talon now batman in this movie has
similar quill-lined gauntlets that talon
wears i'm just thinking it is possible
that thinking he was a good guy
vigilante all this time batman has
actually been doing the bidding of a
corrupt police force carrying out the
vision of his cruel elitist father and
now he justifies as vengeance actually
unjustified brutality against poor
trick-or-treaters next clip
take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there yeah we see more
of this crazy violence as batman beats a
piss out of some security guards at what
i think might be cobblepot's nightclub
the iceberg lounge batman grabs the bat
and hits the guard with the other end
knocking out his earpiece vengeance
ventures for what even cobblepot is like
hey take it easy sweetheart he accuses
him of being exactly what the ghost
stories describe him as and it might be
true on to the next clip
i'm vengeance
here selena leaps off this ledge again
this is the same building where gordon
lit the bat signal from actually in the
lower right of frame you can see batman
wrestling with someone wearing glasses
this could be nashton after his release
from prison then batman viciously
charges down a fancy hallway he just
gobbles up those bullets with the only
light coming from the gunfire i love
this actually the director of
photography on this film was greg
frazier who was the same guy who shot
the movie rogue one in a number of
mandalorian episodes and with michael
giacchino's score evoking the imperial
march from star wars yeah this totally
seems like a recreation of darth vader's
blackout kill box in the quarter one of
my favorite star wars sequences at the
end of rogue one shot by the same
cinematographer and we see the batmobile
this movie an awesome looking muscle car
i love how they put the camera in these
impossible close-ups right on the
batman's hand as he cranks up the engine
like increasing the burn of a jet engine
and then somehow gets the camera right
there at his feet as he stomps on the
accelerator meaning that they had to rig
up a version of this car that was like a
cross-section of it that didn't have the
rest of the body of the car moving on
what's black
and blue
and dead all over
okay next batman perches on this clock
tower wearing a wingsuit glider gear
escaping the police i like how they
mount the camera on his back to show
that last cop trying to reach out and
grab him as he leaps off the ledge i
actually assume this is the tower that
he ascended in the previous trailer as
place fired upon him so at some point
batman's relationship with the cops
turns sour then there's this awesome
looking shot of batman caked in mud i
actually think this could be after he
leads a group with the flare into that
flooded area perhaps one of the
riddler's clues led them there that
could be something that unearths that
whole infrastructure conspiracy and then
nashton's voice asks what is black and
blue and dead all over a play on the
whole newspaper joke what's black and
white and red all over which nashton
literally does by painting the red word
lies over black and white newspaper but
in this case the answer is you which
must be to taunt batman's bruised body
as he tried to play cop the boys in blue
now you may see this as a nod to the
black and blue nightwing dick grayson
though as this is a younger batman i
don't know if he would have had a
nightwing or a robin at this point and
then we learned that nashton live
streamed some of his riddles on social
media where he wears his military
extreme cold weather mask but wears his
glasses over it just a nice little
detail similar to the zodiac killer the
way he was described by victims as
wearing a mask but wearing glasses over
the mask and then we see batman angrily
beating the [ __ ] out of somebody if you
push it on the bottom of the frame there
that is totally gnashed in in his mask
and he's hitting him so hard that selena
watches in fear of batman's rage like on
a date with a guy at a sports bar who is
screaming at the tv do i really want to
go home with someone who might kill me
then we see someone in latex gloves
unfolding note reading see you in hell
on a scratched card of a dark green
color that's not a riddle i kind of
wonder if this could be some kind of
fake clue planted to try to frame batman
for all the crimes that ridler committed
this could be what leads the cops to
turn on him moving on
i got you
yeah this rules i like how commonbot
celebrates kind of like two-face and
batman forever when he thought that he
had burned batman alive just to have him
leap out of the flames by the way that
val kilmer batman suit was the same one
that robert pattinson tried on for his
screen test when he was auditioning for
this role and then on to the last part
nice the framing of batman walking up to
cobblepot upside down like a bat hanging
in a cave the complete embodiment of
fear and on that title card that bat
emblem is laid inside the text with its
wings and hinges and segments kind of
like the bat emblem on his chest but
that central region with the pointed
ears looks less mechanical and more
hand-drawn almost like a sketch of a
child of the monster under his bed in
this film having a title like the batman
it's referring to the vigilante as a
folk legend feared by gotham's
underworld which is why i think this
batman might be more of a mantra's lie
working in the shadows of gotham more of
a villain than bruce wayne may realize
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me at eavos subscribing
to new rockstars breakdowns everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you